you're a supporter of Boris Johnson
throughout this you're in the minority
there aren't you I don't believe I am
certainly the members I've spoken to
certainly people in my constituency
think this is a massive overreach here
we think he's been treated very very
unfairly from the start now I haven't
said too much I've waited for the report
to come out I think you have to do that
and you have to treat the committee with
respect and to be able to do its
conclusions without being interfered
with but now I've read them uh really I
I think people's worst fears have been
confirmed there and Boris Johnson quite
rightly has had a rebuttal of many of
those things now obviously they must
have some kind of crystal ball and see
into people's minds and what they
knowingly did but this 90-day suspension
and taking somebody's pass off though
and now any reasonable person can think
that that's an acceptable punishment I
don't know Jane well well that's partly
we understand heightened because the
fact that he breached the committee's
confidentiality by releasing a press
release on Friday night when he wasn't
meant to so fundamentally he he appears
to have shown a certain amount of
disregard and contempt for the committee
which they they have spelled out
this was was a system that that he
created he's been hoisted with his own
petard here hasn't he well I think in
terms of confidentiality I think most of
us have been getting a running
commentary of what's been going on
because the times has been putting it
over Twitter most of the time so in
terms of wherever this has come from it
certainly hasn't been Boris Johnson uh I
know if I had had these allegations
leveled at me I'd want to defend myself
Boris Johnson's issued a very lengthy
statement now where he's gone into quite
specific detail about a lot of things
that I think he's right to do that but
of course he's he doesn't feel he's been
fairly treated and I think when people
pre-judge you look at the former chair
had to recuse himself quite rightly uh
In fairness from being on the committee
and then has been replaced by somebody
who is again prejudged made comments in
advance now you would not accept that in
a court of law and it's all to do with
due process and fairness that's what the
public wants to see and I don't think we
see that here
this committee essentially found that
not it's not that Boris broke the rules
Boris Johnson broke the rules in in
having these events it's that he came to
Parliament he knew he'd broke the rules
he'd asked his uh colleagues if he'd
broken the rules they said we think yeah
broke the rules don't say you haven't in
Parliament and he still went ahead and
said so in Parliament it's lying to
Parliament that's fundamentally it's
showing a disregard for the Democratic
structure of our country Boris was very
clear in the evidence he got that he was
giving that statement with the
information that had been provided to
him now when I was a minister I would
have uh statements prepared for me I'd
read them off and if you make a mistake
or the information is wrong sometimes
you'll come back to the house and you
will correct that and Boris Johnson did
that when he was made aware that there
were things going on that he wasn't
particularly but he said that he then
lied again to them as a committee
well I think that's a little unfair
really I mean Boris Johnson again he's
given a a very open account of himself
he's given a very detailed account of
what he's actually done there and really
they've got no evidence at all or proof
that he knowingly misled the house and I
think this is a very very unfair on
Boris Johnson but I think it also has
some quite serious consequences for the
rest of us as Member of Parliament now I
feel very very uneasy with MPS removing
other MPS or having that decision we are
put there by the electorate by the
people of this country and yes we do
have to maintain maintain standards but
we should not have people going after
people that they don't like having
opinions on them and being able to
remove them from the House of Commons
and I think that is very very wrong
they say he lied voters want MPS
especially especially MPS who are the
prime minister to tell the truth
well absolutely and as Boris Johnson has
said he believed with what he was saying
was was the case at the time and when he
found out that some of that information
was wrong he went and corrected that now
what you've also got is uh various
arguments that overreach for example
things concerned with the Metropolitan
Police uh it's very clear what the the
law actually is there was only one
incident where a fine was issued there
if I'm honest I don't think I'd have
accepted a final many of my constituents
would with that but the Prime Minister
put his uh at the time put his hands up
as did the current prime minister I
thought again that was very unfair that
fine that was there and that was the
only thing that is mentioned I think
it's gone far beyond that remit where
it's actually almost interpreting and
making up the law itself as to what they
think the law should be and now of
course there are questions arising about
other people's conduct as well now I
would hope I wouldn't make any
conclusions about that at all until
they've had a fair hearing they've been
listened to and I won't prejudge them on
that unfortunately that's not a courtesy
that's been extended Boris Johnson
you say that you don't think you're in
the minority in terms of coming here to
defend him and support him uh but but
from those we've spoken to it appears
the majority of conservative MPS largely
want him to shut up I mean we will find
out next week when when this report has
presented the house and MPS get an
opportunity to vote on it what what the
majority of conservatives do think but
do you accept that he is still damaging
the conservative party well I wouldn't
have had this in the first place I think
it's wasted a lot of parliamentary time
I think we could be getting on with a
legislative agenda and a lot more
important things that are going on there
and people want to see an end to it and
I completely get that and we've had a
we've had a very difficult year uh the
polling is very difficult and divided
parties don't win elections so I do hope
that we're able to come together and put
this behind us but before then I think
there's some unfinished business and
this needs dealing with on Monday Brenda
Cox Smith we appreciate you coming in
and talk to us thank you